Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Jetzt ist sie ein paar Monate her, die WM 2018 in Russland, aber ist jetzt eigentlich irgendwas geblieben von diesem Hype? Diese Frage kann uns nur die einzig wahre Katrin Scheib beantworten, die in Moskau lebt, immer noch. Katrin, wie schön dich mal wieder im Rasenfunk zu haben. Hallo.
Du bist der Teil davon. Ach komm, du hast doch extra gesagt, dass ich dich so begrüßt habe.
Genau, genau. Die 50 Euro gibts dann auch später. Du bist der Teil davon. Ohne die Kurzpässe mit dir zur WM. Die haben da sicherlich auch ihr Schaflein zu beigetragen. Also vielen Dank auch an dich. Wir haben uns auch sehr, sehr gefreut. Und das Fallen geht gleich weiter. Soll ich dir mal verraten, der wievielte Kurzpass das hier ist? Nummer 100. Unglaublich. Und ich finde das ja passend, dass wir zwei miteinander sprechen. Ich habe extra nochmal nachgeguckt. Siebenmal haben wir gesprochen über die Situation in Russland. Und jetzt eben ein achtes Mal, was das ja so ein bisschen beschließt. Das ist natürlich traurig. Aber wir werden schon andere Anlässe noch irgendwie finden, oder? Oder? Klar, warum denn auch nicht? Wobei, in Deutschland auch schon. Ja, und ihr habt seit einiger Zeit Heizung, also Wärme. Das freut mich, nachdem das zentral geregelt wird. Das ist Wahnsinn. Moskau ist ja so ein bisschen wie ein Regionalzug der Deutschen Bahn, wo auch der Lokführer, wenn er nicht auf einen bestimmten Knopf drückt, dann ist die Klimaanlage einfach überall nicht an. Oder eben auch die Heizung. Und so ist es mit der ganzen Stadt Moskau, habe ich bei dir im Blog gelernt.
In großen Städten wird einfach die Heizung zentral an- und abgeschaltet. Insofern ja, stimmt. Ist so ein bisschen wie im Regionalexpress. Was, glaube ich, nicht im Regionalexpress ist, ist, dass dann auch im Frühjahr immer noch so eine Woche, 10 Tage das Wasser abgedreht wird, jedenfalls das Warme. Weil dann die Leitungen gewartet werden. Aber ja, schöne Analogie. Aber ist egal, ist alles gut geheizt jetzt. Aktuell habe ich hier drin, denn du kannst ja dann auch, es heizt mir dann auch alle um mich rum, du kannst also nur sehr bedingt beeinflussen, wie warm es bei dir ist. Also aktuell ist es sicher bei 23 Grad.
Ach ja, Wahnsinn. Das ist doch schön knackig. Und das mit dem Wasser hattest du uns sogar in irgendeinem der vergangenen Sieben kurz per Semal erzählt und hast noch rausgelassen, dass du ja ein Boiler hattest.
Genau, weil das war die Zeit.
Ja, und außerdem haben die damals ja geregelt, dass es so verschoben wird, dass es während der WM nicht war. Du hast total recht, guck mal, was du dich noch erinnerst.
Ja, naja, das wäre ja schlimm, wenn ich mich an unsere Gespräche nicht erinnern könnte. Aber das bringt uns ja schon wie über eine goldene Brücke, als hätten wir es geplant und das war jetzt mal nicht geplant. Bringt uns das ja zum Thema. Ja, jetzt ist die WM ja wirklich schon eine ganze Weile her. Die Folge wird auch für viele Hörern und Hörern wie aus dem Nichts kommen. Was ist denn geblieben von der WM-Atmosphäre, vom WM-Hype?
Also ganz ehrlich, im Alltag, wenn du hier so durch Moskau gehst, nicht viel. Also normal ist ja, das ist jetzt nicht typisch Moskau, typisch russische WM. Natürlich wird auch mal eine ganze Deko abgehängt und die Wanner kommen weg und die Maskottchen kommen weg. Und selbst der Supermarkt von uns gegenüber hat irgendwann seinen Aufsteller mit den ganzen russischen Souvenirs, also spezifischen WM-Souvenirs in diesem WM-Design beiseite geschoben. Es gibt hier den neuen Abad, das ist so eine große Hauptstraße, sehr zentral gelegen. Und da gibt es auf einer Ecke, wo dann eine andere Straße abgeht, schon sehr lange so einen riesigen, auf so einem Dach, so einen riesigen beleuchteten Globus, den hatten sie jetzt im WM ja als Fußballumstalt. Das ist jetzt wieder ein Globus. Also ist alles so ein bisschen wieder zurück auf Anfang.
Aber sind denn die englischsprachigen Straßenschilder oder U-Bahnschilder zum Beispiel geblieben?
Jaja, die sind geblieben. Das ist auch eine schöne Sache. Das wäre ja auch mehr Aufwand, die wieder abzumontieren, als sie zu lassen. Also es ist ja einfach Trägheit, die schon allein dafür sorgt, dass das jetzt so bleibt. Die andere Frage ist halt, also das eine ist die Schilder. Da brauchst du ja keine Menschen, die mitziehen. Das andere ist so ein bisschen die Leute, die im Sommer halt hier dann ja sehr darauf getrimmt waren und darum gebeten waren, sei nett zu den Leuten, auch wenn sie kein Russisch können, helft ihnen und so weiter. Das ist zum Teil jetzt schon wieder sehr anders. Wir waren vor drei Wochen hier bei dem Schalke-Auswärtsspiel, bei Lokomotiv, und fuhren beim Stadion an und waren da mit Leuten verabredet. Und das heißt, wir hatten unsere Karten noch nicht, die hatten die. Und die hatten einen Erklärpunkt, uns treten am Gästeblog. Und wir haben den Gästeblog nicht gefunden. Und draußen, es war ein ursleiger Tag, muss man sagen, es hat geregnet und draußen stand halt Polizeikordern rum, alles halt große Männer in so dunklen Regencaves. Und ich bin dann halt auch zu einem und hab gesagt, na ja, wir kennen das jetzt, wir wissen jetzt, wie es funktioniert. Freunde und Helfer. Und hab gefragt, Entschuldigung, blablabla, wo ist denn hier der Gästeeingang? Und kam nix.
Wie nix, also gar nichts?
Nichts, gar keine Reaktionen, kein Blickkontakt, kein Gehen Sie weg. Ich hab gedacht, vielleicht hast du es schlecht erklärt. Und dann haben wir gesagt, der Eingang ist für die Deutschen und für die Schalke-Fans. Und wo muss ich hin? Dann können Sie mir sagen, komplett ignoriert. Ich hätte auf dem Glas sein können und kein Geräusch machen. Und das war so surreal, weil zwei Schritte weiter, als du an den Polizisten, also den Staatlichen, den Offiziellen vorbei warst, Ordner war nett, auf dem Gelände gab es sogar Durchsagen, zwischendurch so auf Deutsch, schlicht, aber das, was du halt brauchst, um dich zu orientieren, was einfach zeigt, was war verordnet, und was sind vielleicht, also Polizisten, die es irgendwie, ich muss jetzt hier nicht mehr nett sein, keiner hat mir gesagt, dass ich weiterhin nett sein muss, oder eben Leute, die wirklich für Fußball stehen und für einen Verein stehen oder vielleicht, also Interesse haben, dass über dieses Turnier hinausgehen. Das war ein ganz interessanter Kontrast.
Ja, glaube ich. Ich habe auch irgendwann zwei Wochen nach der WM einen Tweet gelesen von jemandem aus Russland. Und die schrieb, ich habe soeben beobachtet, wie mehrere Polizisten einen Mann mit einer Bierflasche in der Hand auf der Straße angesprochen haben, jetzt ist die WM offiziell vorbei.
Total, trifft es. Die ganzen Sachen, die hier im Sommer irgendwie lästig, entspannt, quasi südländische Lebensfreude waren, das ist jetzt soweit wieder durch. Nicht weil die Leute nicht feiern möchten oder nicht gut gelaunt sind, sondern weil jetzt wieder Bild, was vorher galt und auf der Straße trinken, geht gar nicht.
Gut, ich meine, das war ja schon zu befürchten, dass der Fußball da so schnell irgendetwas verändern würde. Das glauben ja auch nur die bei der FIFA. Und vielleicht wollen sie es auch nur glauben oder auch nur so tun, als würden sie es glauben. Du hast auch in einer Nebenbemerkung bei dir in deinem Newsletter was, glaube ich, geschrieben, dass jetzt auch die Obdachlosen wieder mehr zu sehen sind. Das fand ich ganz interessant. Waren die verschwunden? Kann man festmachen, warum die aus dem Stadtbett oder wie die aus dem Stadtbett rausgedrängt wurden?
Ein bisschen kann man das. Also generell, grundsätzlich ist es schon so, dass im wirklichen, richtigen touristischen Zentrum, also Runterplatz, Kreml und so weiter, da wird dir nie die totale Armut entgegenschlagen. Da wird auch einfach gesorgt. Das ist halt für Touristen nicht wohl für besonderes Geld ausgeben. Und klar, also wenn du jetzt am Roten Platz bist, da ist an der Ecke die Kasanerkathedrale. Das ist sehr viel kleinerer Kirche, als das Wort Kathedrale es vermuten lässt, aber eine sehr schöne kleine Kirche. Da stehen Leute vor, die betteln oder um Geld bitten, um Almosen bitten, das ist aber halt üblich für russischen Kirchen. Oder da steht an einem Tor, durch das man auf den Roten Platz geht, steht immer einer. Aber während der WM war halt noch sehr viel mehr auch so über das kleine Zentrum hinaus darauf geachtet, da war offensichtlich der Wunsch bei den Stadtoberen, sich dadurch nicht das Stadtbild, das ist jetzt sehr in Anführungsstrichen nicht meine Meinung, sondern deren, dominieren zu lassen. Und sich nicht so der Welt zu präsentieren. Es gibt zum Beispiel, es gibt hier an einer Ecke in Moskau so drei Bahnhöfe auf relativ kurzen, engem Raum. Und da gab es immer so ein Zelt, wo Obdachlose versorgt wurden, nicht nur mit Essen, sondern auch medizinisch. Die haben da ihre Diabetes spritzen, zum Beispiel Abholung feilen. Oder so Grundversorgung. Und die Hilfsorganisation, die dieses Zelt betrieben hat, hat dann kurz vor der WM eine Ansage gekriegt. Ja, euer Zelt muss hier weg. Das kann während der WM hier nicht stehen. Und da mussten die halt an den totalen Stadtrand. Was schwierig ist, weil, also ich meine, das ist schon schwierig für jemanden dorthin zu gründen, der mobil ist, der Geld hat und der in der Lage ist, seinen Tag so zu gestalten, wie er sich das vorstellt. Jemand, der auf der Straße lebt, der durch viele Widerstände ausgesetzt ist, der zum Teil auch krank oder geschwächt oder zum Teil auch alkoholkrank ist, je nachdem, was seine Baustellen sind. Du kannst dir vorstellen, dass das ein großes Loch gerissen hat, dass die Versorgungsanlaufstelle plötzlich nicht mehr da war. Und jetzt ist halt, wie du sagst, es ist einigen Monate her. Ja, und jetzt steht zum Beispiel hier bei uns an der Ecke, also drei Häuser weiter von uns vor so einem kleinen Supermarkt, da stand halt immer der gleiche Mann. Nicht jeden Tag, aber alle paar Tage steht er da mit seinem Becher. Und jetzt, den habe ich während der WM nicht einen Tag gesehen, und jetzt steht er wieder da. Oder in eine andere Richtung, Richtung zum großen Einkaufszentrum hier ins Eck. Auf der Verkehrsinsel in der Mitte, wenn man die Straße überquert, da saß immer einer und der sitzt jetzt eben wieder da. Weil sich jetzt eben wieder dürfen und weil das Image der Stadt jetzt nicht mehr ganz so hochklassifiziert ist.
Ich meine, muss man jetzt auch nicht wahnsinnig überrascht darüber sein, wenn man einfach nur mal drauf achtet, wie es in deutschen Innenstädten ist. Also ich hier als Münchner kann sagen, da wird schon auch viel dafür getan, dass du gewisse Personengruppen wie durch Zauberhand auf einmal nicht siehst. Und wenn man in anderen Städten ist, dann fällt einem das nämlich richtig auf. Aber es ist natürlich trotzdem nochmal wichtig, darüber zu reden, finde ich, dass man sich das eben bewusst macht.
Also ich war noch nicht so oft in München, aber wenn ich in Deutschland bin, bist du für mich dann oft irgendwo in Rheinland, Köln zum Beispiel. Und da fällt mir auf, dass das sehr viel sichtbarer ist als in Moskau. Und sehr viel mehr zugelassen wird auch. Dass Menschen, die einen schönen Tag haben wollen, trotzdem mit dem Thema konfrontiert sind, dass es sich jedem so gut geht wie ihnen. Und dass man da vielleicht helfen kann.
Und wie ist das jetzt mit dem Lebensgefühl der Menschen? Da haben wir ja auch in unserer letzten Folge, direkt nach der WM, ein bisschen darüber gesprochen, wie sich das angefühlt hat, mit fremden Kulturen in Kontakt zu kommen. Und dass das ja vielleicht auch im Geist der Leute etwas bewegt. Also ohne, dass man jetzt gleich glaubt. Das kann ein ganzes Land, wir können vier Wochen verändern. Aber es bleibt einem ja haften, wenn man mit peruanischen Fans einen tollen Abend hatte, wenn man gesehen hat, wie schön das ist, wenn man sich mit anderen Kulturen trifft. Spürst du davon noch etwas in deiner Umgebung?
Ich habe dazu in letzter Zeit keine großen Beobachtungen machen können. Das hat aber auch etwas damit zu tun, dass die richtige typische Touristenzeit durch ist. Es sind jetzt einfach weniger Leute aus anderen Ländern in Moskau. Natürlich gibt es immer noch Leute in der Nachsaison. Gerade die chinesischen Reisegruppen sind schon immer noch da. Aber es ist insofern schon ein anderes Lebensgefühl, weil es eben nicht mehr Straßencafés, draußen feiern, abends lange sitzen ist. Darum ist man auch weniger in Situationen, wo es sich mischen könnte.
Das Leben verlagert sich ja im Herbst und im Winter.
Genau, wieder nach drinnen. Insofern fällt es mir im Moment schwer, irgendwas zu beobachten, wie international, wie weltoffen sich das jetzt noch anfühlt oder nicht, weil man eben weniger so Situationen erlebt.
Gut, es sind ja auch vier Ausnahmewochen gewesen. Wie ist es denn mit dem russischen Fußball? Konnte der profitieren von der WM und ja auch von dem sehr erfolgreichen Abschneiden der eigenen Nationalmannschaft? Das kommt ja noch mit dazu.
Ja, also ich habe vor zwei Wochen oder so mal angefangen, alle Vereine anzumähen oder jedenfalls die meisten, die heute in Stadien spielen, die WM-Stadien waren. In einigen Fällen war das ja Verein, die wir vorher schon gespielt haben. Große Clubs sind aber teilweise auch kleine, die halt plötzlich unverhofft schicke oder neu renovierte Stadien haben. Und gerade die, bei denen war der Rücklauf so, die haben eigentlich zwei Sachen gesagt. Erstens, sie merken mehr Fans, die kommen zu den Spielen. Zum Teil, das fand ich auch interessant, auch eine andere Zusammensetzung. Mehr auch Frauen, mehr auch Familien, sowas. Also erstens mehr Leute, die kommen. Und zweitens mehr Interesse bei Kindern und Jugendlichen. An so Sachen wie Fußballschule, Probetraining. Also einer hat auch gesagt, bei ihm in der Stadt haben sich seitens der WM eine Handvoll oder so private neue Fußballschulen gegründet. Das sind halt Sachen, das ist ja, wie du sagst, das sind ja nicht immer extrem unmittelbare Auswirkungen. Aber wenn eben jetzt eine WM ist und das dazu führt, dass jetzt eben, weiß ich nicht, sechs-, sieben-, achtjährige verstärkt Interesse an Fußball haben, dann ist das ja ganz interessant. Wie ist das dann in zehn Jahren? Wenn das Leute sind, die halt professionell spielen könnten. Das fand ich schon interessant.
Und das heißt, die Nutzung der Stadion ist auch überall gewährleistet. Also wir haben jetzt in Russland keine weißen Elefanten rumstehen, wie zum Beispiel in Südafrika oder Brasilien ja auch.
Na ja, definieren gewährleistet. Also ich meine, ist so ein Stadion in Sochi ausgelastet, wenn da jeden zweiten Spieltag dieser eine Verein spielt, ne? Das ist, also nominell ist das ein Stadion und das hat einen Verein.
Es wird immerhin noch drin gespielt. Na ja, das haben wir ja bei manchen Stadien in Südafrika oder in Brasilien nicht gehabt.
Ja, okay. Wenn du die Latte so anlegst, dann ja. Aber das sind immer noch relativ viele Tage im Jahr, die frei sind. Und das gerade in Russland, wo ja, da haben wir ja auch schon oft drüber gesprochen, selbst große Vereine ihre Stadien ganz oft nicht vollkriegen. Oder jedenfalls nicht. Die sich die Stadien nicht rentieren über den Fußball, der dort stattfindet, sondern über große Konzerte und andere Veranstaltungen, die dort gemacht werden. Es soll ja demnächst hier mal wieder ein neues, saniertes Stadion eröffnet werden, das Dynamo-Stadion. Das sollte, glaube ich, jetzt auch schon mehrfach, ich glaube im August schon mal oder im September eröffnet werden, aber demnächst jetzt dann auch ganz garantiert wirklich. Und ich weiß gar nicht, was denn stand, seit sie das letzte Mal verschoben haben. Aber ursprünglich sollte das eröffnet werden mit einem Konzert von Imagine Dragons, weil eben die viele Stadien hier sehr klar sich eben als Multifunktionsarenen darauf angelegt sind und sich auch nur so rentieren. Und wenn du das dann eben im Hinterkopf hast, dass selbst die großen Stadien mit den zu kräftigen Vereinen sich nicht tragen können, wenn sie nicht ordentlich so Zusatzveranstaltungen heranschaffen, dann kannst du dir vorstellen, was das für ein Stadion in, zum Beispiel Sochi ist ein echt wunderschöner Filmstadion heißt. Also das kann natürlich im Leben nicht rentabel sein.
Ja, gut, das ist leider, leider habe ich da tatsächlich in meinem Kopf die Latte sehr niedrig angesetzt. Da hast du völlig zu Recht darauf hingewiesen. Das stimmt schon. Ich habe aber gelesen, dass in den ersten Spieltagen der russischen Liga nach der WM das Zuschauerinteresse schon deutlich höher war als sonst. Am vierten Spieltag hat man sogar den ewigen Liga-Zuschauerrekord fast erreicht. Hat sich denn das jetzt auch gehalten? Jetzt kommt ja wieder die Zeit, wo es auch ein bisschen unangenehmer wird.
Ja, genau, das flaut gerade so ein bisschen ab. Das haben auch die Leute von den Vereinen, mit denen ich gesprochen habe, gesagt. Das Spannende wird jetzt natürlich zu sehen. Man muss an mehreren Stellen spannen. Das ist zu sehen. Spannend zu sehen hält es durch den Winter, weil es ursächlich ist. Und du stehst vorher herum und du stehst nachher herum. Es ist kalt, es regnet. Auch abseits der Winterpause hast du ziemlich viel schlechtes Wetter. Oder mal kalt, niedrige Temperaturen. Und das andere ist natürlich auch, selbst wenn es vielleicht im Winter etwas abnimmt, was es auch schon getan hat, auch bei den Vereinen, die zuerst einen kleinen Schwung gesehen haben. Was ist denn, wenn der nächste Sommer kommt? Ich glaube, das ist richtig interessant. Auf welches Level schwingt das dann zurück? Auf das Level vor der WM oder auf das Level in der Spielzeit? Aber nach der WM. Da zeigt sich dann eben, hat sich da etwas Grundsätzliches geändert? Oder war das mehr so ein Strohfeuer? Das wird nächsten, ja, weiß ich nicht, so Mai, Juni, Juli, das wird richtig interessant.
Und dann können wir auch gucken, ob es dann vielleicht doch noch mal Bier mit Alkohol in den Stadion geben wird.
Du hast interessant, du kannst den Münchener nicht verleugnen mit deinen Prioritäten.
Ja, aber schwere Politik kriegt man schon auch noch.
Aber jetzt erstmal die Bier-Frage, wie wollt ihr das abhaken? Wichtiges Thema. Bis jetzt sieht es nicht danach aus, was ich bemerkenswert finde. Also es hieß ja auch immer mal, wir lassen das Wohlwollen prüfen. Putin fand die Idee ja auch ganz gut. Aber irgendwie habe ich da zuletzt keine Bewegung mehr gesehen. Und hier bei einem der diversen Champions-League-Spiele, die wir neulich hatten, hat ein Fußballreporter hier von AP, der war vor dem Stadion und schrieb noch sehr hübsch mit einem Foto. Guck mal, vor, weiß ich nicht, x Wochen wurde hier noch Bier mit Alkohol drin ausgeschenkt. Und jetzt stehen alle hier und wollen irgendeinen Energy-Drink, der hier verteilt wird. Weil das irgendwie so das eigentlich Interessante ist, was sie hier finden. Also nee, das ist tatsächlich, da hätte ich mit gerechnet, dass das schneller passiert. Und ist es irgendwie nicht.
Gut, ich meine, wir haben ja über das Problem des Alkoholismus auch gesprochen. Ich fand es nur so eine nette Rand-Anekdote, weil es das Umgedrehte war. Also in Deutschland ist es so, zu Champions-League-Spielen kriegst du diese alkoholfreie Plörre. Und zu guten Bundesliga-Spielen, außer sind natürlich hochsicherheits-Spiele, was wahrscheinlich, wenn es nach manchen geht, jetzt jedes Spiel inzwischen wäre in Deutschland. Dann musst du damit Vorlieb nehmen. Und in Russland hatten wir jetzt genau die umgedrehte Situation, was ja interessant ist. Und da bin ich übrigens auch schon sehr, sehr gespannt, wie sie das mit Katar machen wollen.
Also, da wird...
Ja, ich habe jetzt nicht im Kopf, wie lange da der Biersponsor bei der FIFA noch mit drin hängt. Aber sollte der noch irgendwie eingeplant sein für 2022, dann wird es da haarig. Aber gut, da werden wir uns dann in ein paar Jahren mit beschäftigen. Meine Lieblingsfrage, die würde ich am liebsten, hätte ich eine Webseite gebaut, die wasmachteigendlichvitalymutko.de heißt. Willst du kurz nochmal für alle hören und höre die nicht mehr genau im Kopf haben, mit wem wir es da zu tun haben. Du musst nicht alle seine Titel nennen, aber was waren denn so seine wichtigsten Funktionen vor der WM und was macht er denn jetzt?
Ja, Mutko, der Mann ist immer gut ausgelastet gewesen, mit sportlichen und politischen Ämtern. Er war früher schon Präsident von Zenit in Petersburg, Präsident von russischem Fußballverband, er war Sportminister, er hatte FIFA-Ämter, er war der russische WM-Beauftragte. Und gleichzeitig war er auch Sportminister während Sochi. Und der eine oder andere wird sich an das große russische Staatsklubbing-Thema an Sochi erinnern. Und das war eben unter Mutko. Und je länger sich die Berichterstattung darüber hinzog, je mehr Details da ans Licht kamen, desto weniger wirkte er offenbar tragbar. Und darum haben sie ihn ja vor der WM so ein bisschen aus der Schusslinie genommen. Ach, das ist ein blödes militäristisches Bild. Also aus der Öffentlichkeit rausgeholt. Und damit, glaube ich, er keine nicht so viel Eingriffsfläche bietet. Und damit er auch nicht das Straßenbild stört. Nur halt im übertragenden Sinne. Er hat dann ja sein, wie war das, erstes Amt als Präsident des Fußballverbandes ruhen lassen. Dann auch das als Chef hier vom WMOK. Ja, und nun hört man in den letzten Tagen, dass das vielleicht jetzt auch mal reicht. Und das WMOK ja jetzt vielleicht wieder beim Verband eine aktivere Rolle. Mal sehen, es ist alles noch nicht vollzogen. Aber wie gesagt, es verschärfen sich die Gerüchte, dass der Mann bald wieder das eine oder andere Amt hat. Der war ja, als er noch Sportminister war, da bist du dann, wie heißt das, den Rang eines Vizepremierministers mit Zuständigkeit für. Und da war er eben einer von. Und das haben sie ja auch irgendwie geändert. Und dann waren seine Zuständigkeiten plötzlich sowas wie Infrastruktur- und Bauprojekte oder sowas. Also ein relativ deutliches, du bist weiter wichtig, du bist weiter versorgt, du behältst so deinen Dienstrang, das darf nur gerade nicht so aussehen, als hättest du irgendwas mit Fußball zu tun.
Genau. Und das bereiten sie jetzt wieder vor, dass er wieder zurückkommen kann?
Ja, also es gibt jetzt hier die ersten Berichte, dass das bald so sein wird.
Es ist auch schön, wenn die Ressourcielisierung mal klappt.
Jaja, auf jeden Fall, genau, das ist ganz wichtig.
Na gut, also was macht Vitali mutko.de? Da können dann bald wieder ein paar neue Einträge mit rein. Vielleicht möchte ja auch eine Hörerin oder ein Hörer da sein.
Was macht eigentlich?
Ja, was macht eigentlich? Man müsste eigentlich jede Woche fragen, was macht eigentlich Vitali Mutko. Denn da kämen bestimmt auch wieder jede Woche neue Dinge mit dazu. Das bringt uns ja aber, wenn wir uns da dran erinnern, dass er eben aus der Schusslinie genommen wurde, als habe ich es auch gesagt, aus der Öffentlichkeit herausgezogen wurde, und auch diesen ganzen Doping komplett. Das bringt uns ja auch so ein bisschen zu so einer Gesamtbewertung des Turniers. Und da wäre ja für die Bevölkerung mit das Wichtigste. Was hat es denn jetzt eigentlich gekostet, diese Weltmeisterschaft? Und was war da dem Gegenüber gestellt, der Ertrag?
Ja, das ist noch ein bisschen schwer zu sagen, weil du ja nicht alles messen kannst. Und weil es natürlich, es gibt die offiziell kommunizierten Zahlen. Und man muss auch ein bisschen gucken, wie valide die sind. Ich habe lustigerweise im russischen Unterricht mit meiner Lehrerin hier einen Kommentar gelesen aus Wedemosti, wo drei Wirtschaftswissenschaftler eben schrieben, viele der Folgen werden sich erst langfristig aus, langfristig zeigen, weil es eben, was bringt eine Investition in Infrastruktur? Was bringen, weil es nicht beste Verkehrswege, wenn sie eben nicht mehr nur genutzt werden, um Fans von A nach B zu bringen, sondern um dort Güter zu transportieren? Oder was bringt es dir denn, wenn so und so viele Leute hier mal als Fans waren und dann erkennen, ja okay, das Land ist jetzt irgendwie zivilisierter als ich dachte, erschließbarer als ich dachte, dann möchte ich vielleicht auch mal Handel treiben. Das ist sehr schwer zu benennen.
Aber sind denn die Infrastrukturmaßnahmen auch so ausgerichtet gewesen, dass das nicht nur der Weg vom Flughafen oder Bahnhof zum Stadion war und zurück, sondern so, dass es auch noch weitergehend sich auswirken könnte?
Also der Klassiker sind exakt das, was du sagst. Es sind halt Flughäfen hübscher, größer, neuer, besser gemacht worden und solche Sachen. Im Gegenteil, rund um Stadion haben wir ja schon gesprochen, da bröckelt es ja manchmal sogar oder wird so weggeschwemmt. Aber ich meine, unterscheid das nicht. Flughäfen sind halt auch wichtig für Leute, die Handel treiben. Und gerade wenn du nicht über die großen Städte hier, die mehr oder weniger direkt noch in Europa liegen, kurz, wenn man nach Russland reinkommt direkt vorne, Petersburg und Moskau, sollen wir mal über die anderen reden, dann ist das ja schon nicht ganz unwichtig, dass Leute wissen, da komme ich gut und gerne und einfach hin. Weil ja eben viele Leute, die vorher nicht in Russland waren, sich auch vielleicht kein akkurates Bild davon machen konnten, wie leicht oder wie schwer es ist, sich hier im Land zu bewegen. Es gab eine offizielle Turnierbilanz und da gab es eine finanzielle Bilanz von den Organisatoren des Turniers. Die Moscow Times hat das ganz gut und relativ knapp zusammengefasst. Die haben gesagt, Russland habe 952 Milliarden Rubel eingenommen. Das sind 14,5 Milliarden Dollar. Dem gegenüber stehen Schätzungen, dass das Ganze gekostet hat, zwischen 11 und 14 Milliarden Dollar. Das wäre dann ein Nullsummenspiel. Andererseits, wenn man mal überlegt große Turniere, da bist du zum Teil schon gut dabei, wenn es ein Nullsummenspiel ist. Das kam auch in diesem Artikel vor, den wir da neulich im russischen Unterricht gelesen haben. Da gibt es Städte wie Lillehammer, das war mir überhaupt nicht klar. Da sind danach die Hotels alle wieder pleite gegangen, die für olympische Spiele da aufgemacht hatten. Weil natürlich, wer reist heute mal eben spontan nach Lillehammer? Also wahrscheinlich ist Nullsummspiel schon gar nicht so ein schlechter Ansatz. Und das ist ja wie gesagt Stand heute. Also ich glaube, spannend wird das in ein, zwei, drei Jahren, wenn man mal gucken kann, was langfristig geblieben ist.
Es ist nicht einfach zu beantworten. Da werden wir in Deutschland auch noch viel drüber diskutieren, dann rund um die Europameisterschaft 2024. Da fangen jetzt schon die Städte an, die Rückstellungen in ihre Budgets einzuplanen. Ich habe das jetzt in München halt näher verfolgen können, wo dann schon die ersten Millionenbeträge eingeplant werden für Infrastrukturmaßnahmen und Dinge, die man machen muss, um der UEFA zu gefallen. Ich bin gerade dabei, das für alle Städte zusammenzutragen. Genau, und die müssen das ja schon rein theoretisch jetzt alle in ihre zukünftigen Haushalte einplanen. Die sind da aber unterschiedlich transparent drüber. Aber das sind schon immer Beträge, bei denen man mit den Ohren schlackert, vor allem, wenn man sich zurück überlegt, das kommt jetzt alles aus Steuergeldern. Und damit ja auch zu ganz kleinen Teilen von einem selbst. Das ist schon interessant. Ein interessantes Thema.
Wann wird entschieden, welche Stadt da darf, also Gastgeber sein darf?
Das ist schon entschieden. Das wusste ich nicht. Das wurde quasi schon vor der Bewerbung entschieden. Und es gab großes Aufsehen darüber, dass Gladbach wieder nicht Austragungsort geworden ist. So wie schon 2006. Und ich glaube, da bin ich mir jetzt aber gerade nicht 100% sicher, dass Düsseldorf wieder mit dabei ist. Ja, Punkt. Den Rest kann man sich...
Ich merke, wie du für mich den NRW-Aspekt herausarbeitest. Und ich weiß das zu schätzen.
Natürlich, natürlich.
Ich werde als Alles Dankeschön einmal für dich, Mönchengladbach, Saar.
Bleiben wir bei schönen Dingen. Und dann reden wir über Putin. Der hat ja...
Interessanter Übergang.
Ich hab da einfach einen Man-Crush. Wenn jemand so gut noch aussieht und auf Bären oder auf Pferden oder auf was auch immer noch reitet, dann kann ich so jemanden nicht schlecht finden. Egal, was er politisch so vertritt. Da sei mir auch zugestanden an der Stelle. Nein, wir haben ja drüber geredet, während der WM und vor der WM, dass normalerweise Beliebtheitswerte im Zuge von solchen Turnieren steigen für diejenigen, die sich im Glanz dieses Turniers sonnen können. Er aber gleichzeitig mit Rentenerhöhungen bzw. es wurde ja das alte Erhöh, zu dem man in Rente gehen kann, schon für großen Unmut gesorgt hat. Ich weiß noch, ich habe es noch so im Hinterkopf, dass du mir damals gesagt hast, so arg profitieren konnte er dann gar nicht so sehr von der WM. Wie ist denn das aktuell? Sind die Rentenerhöhungen jetzt gekommen? Ist das alles so geblieben? Wie ist da so die Stimmung im Land?
Ja, das ist in der Tat ein Thema, das uns bis in den Oktober hinein begleitet hat. Begleitet eigentlich immer noch. Dieses, das Thema Erhöhung des Renteneintrittsalters, also Menschen kriegen später ihre Pension, hat sich wirklich durch den ganzen Sommer bis in den Herbst gezogen, ist auch erst Anfang Oktober oder ganz Ende September, nagellich jetzt nicht fest, dann wirklich gesetzt geworden. Und Putin hat, stand Anfang dieses Monats, seine niedrigsten Popularitätswerte seit der Annexion der Krim. Gut, das war ja ein Schritt, der massive Popularität in der Bevölkerung gebracht hat. Also das war ein sehr hoher Wert. Aber aktuell, 58% der Russen sagen, sie vertrauen Putin. Und das waren letztes Jahr 75%. Und wenn man was Ähnliches sucht, wo es schon mal so niedrig war, also zum Beispiel 2012 waren es schon mal 51% im Vergleich zu 58%. Aber da muss man schon richtig gucken. Und wenn du überlegst, du hast es ja angesprochen, dass man sich von so einer Großveranstaltung, so einem Turnier eigentlich so einen Boost verspricht, dass da die Popularität mal so richtig gewinnt. Und jetzt hat er es, wenn man es mal gegeneinander rechnet, gerade geschafft zu verhindern, dass das noch viel schlimmer aussieht. Wir haben ja gerade auch über Geld gesprochen. Das ist schon verdammt viel Geld für verdammt wenig Imagepolitur. Jedenfalls was Putin angeht. Dass das für das Image von Russland sehr viel getan hat. Sei es als Handelspartner, sei es als Urlaubsort und so weiter. Das ist sicherlich eine andere Baustelle. Und er hat da auch durchaus noch nachjustiert. Als wir das letzte Mal sprachen, stand noch im Raum, dass für Männer das Rentenalter von 60 auf 65 gesetzt werden sollte. Und für Frauen von 55 auf 63. Das ist nachjustiert worden. Das heißt, Frauen müssen auch etwas länger warten können, aber statt wie geplant mit 63, mit 60 immerhin in den Rente gehen. Und trotz alledem, trotz nachjustieren, trotz, ob das ein Thema ist, was sich lange hinkriegt, und trotz WM dieser Einbruch in der Popularität, das ist schon sehr, sehr deutlich.
Ja, interessant. Die Eingabe des Gesetzes wurde ja so ein bisschen im WM-Kontext gemacht. Da konnte man spekulieren. Vielleicht war da die Hoffnung, dass das so ein bisschen durchrutscht. Ist es aber nicht. Und ich habe mal was gelesen von Demonstrationen in 150 russischen Städten. Das ist dann schon sehr, sehr schwerwiegend und ist ja auch eine gravierende Entscheidung.
Im Juni, als das vorgestellt wurde, waren neun von zehn Russen dagegen. Und das war aus dem Stand.
Da hatte noch niemand irgendwie mobilisiert oder so.
Solche Werte hast du hier in Deutschland nur, wenn du sagst, wollen wir ein Tempolimit auf Autobahnen, da sind dann auch neun von zehn dagegen, wahrscheinlich. Bleiben wir bei angenehmen Themen. Vom Tempolimit, Putin, Geld, Mutko. Heute haben wir echt eine leichte Sendung.
Du hast heute aber auch Ironietage im Hause Ost, oder?
Ja, wie soll man sonst über so schwere Themen hinwegkommen? Ich weiß nicht, woran es liegt. Vielleicht die Aussicht auf einen rauschenden DFB-Pokal-Abend heute Abend noch. Das hat mich wahrscheinlich in eine ganz besondere ironische Stimmung gesetzt. Aber ich möchte mit dir noch über Pussy Riot sprechen, an die wir uns ja noch vom WM-Finale erinnern. Da wurden dann diejenigen Mitglieder, die da in dieser Flitzer-Aktion gegen Polizeiautorität und andere Dinge demonstriert haben, festgesetzt. Es gab dann später noch mal ein Video, das hat auch ein bisschen die Runde gemacht. Zwei der Aktivistinnen, die dann frei kamen, wurden dann direkt hinter den Gefängnistoren gesagt, jetzt seid ihr noch mal für 15 Tage inhaftiert. Dann mussten sie wieder umdrehen. Das war insofern ein sehr emotionales Video, weil man richtig sehen konnte, wie in dem Blick etwas zerbrochen ist, dass sie wieder zurück mussten ins Gefängnis. Wie ist denn da der aktuelle Stand?
Also ganz kurz noch mal zu dem, was du sagst. Das ist natürlich extrem demonstrativ so eine Entscheidung, das dann zu machen, wenn alle Leute drauf gucken, was mit diesen Frauen geschieht. Und das ist natürlich ein Signal nicht nur an diese beiden Frauen. Und weil du sagtest, Protest gegen Polizeiautorität, also durchaus auch Protest gegen Polizeigewalt. Das war deutlicher als nur, es geht nicht darum, dass es eine Autorität ist, die wir nicht anerkennen. Sonst ist wirklich der Umgang mit Demonstranten, mit Leuten in Gefängnissen und so weiter. Das waren ja mehrere Leute, die damals beim Finale aufs Spielfeld gerannt sind bei dieser Protestaktion. Und einer, ich hoffe, wer es ist, der hat glaube ich in den deutschen Medien auch stattgefunden, dass der ja vergiftet worden ist. Allem Anschein nach. Er hatte jedenfalls schwere Vergiftungserscheinungen. Ist er dann nach Deutschland gebracht worden, in der Charité behandelt worden.
Genau.
Ja und also, hat das jetzt einen direkten WM-Zusammenhang schwer zu sagen? Sagt es so was aus, wie leicht oder gefährlich es ist, in Russland ein politisch aktiver protestierender Mensch zu sein? Natürlich. Also natürlich kann keiner sagen, war das jetzt aufgrund dieser WM-Aktion, dieser Protestaktion beim Finale, oder war das wegen anderen Sachen, woran seine Redaktion, seinen Projekt mit der Sona, woran die recherchieren. Es gibt ja auch noch andere Themen, an denen die dran sind. Das wird dir hier niemand so genau sagen können. Aber es ist eben klar, es zeigt auch jetzt, wo eben die Öffentlichkeit nicht mehr so genau nach Russland guckt. Sofort fehlt halt auch so eine Art Schutz, den Öffentlichkeit eben bietet.
Ja und also er hat dann ein Interview gegeben der Deutschen Welle, das werde ich auch verlinken in den Show Notes. Er sagt, dass er diese Vergiftung überlebt hätte, das sei seiner Meinung nach eine Warnung gewesen. Und er bringt es auch eher in Zusammenhang mit dem Tod, dem etwas mysteriösen Tod von drei russischen Journalisten von einem kremelkritischen Journalismus-Kollektiv, die in Zentralafrika auf Recherchentour waren und dort ermordet wurden unter nicht geklärten Umständen im Zusammenhang mit russischen Söldnern, die dort wohl nicht ganz legale Dinge tun wollen. Er bringt das selbst nicht in Kontext zur WM, ist aber natürlich interessant. Ich habe mir dann die Frage gestellt, ich habe von diesen drei ermordeten Journalisten erfahren, Zapp hat da einen Bericht zu gemacht, das Medienmagazin, aber ansonsten habe ich davon nichts gehört. Und dann erst, als er in der Charité war, dort behandelt wurde und dieses Interview gegeben hat, wurde diese Verknüpfung hergestellt. Ich habe mir dann immer die Frage gestellt, hätte ich jetzt von diesen Vorkommnissen in Zentralafrika in deutschen Medien etwas mitbekommen, wenn das nicht über Bande diesen WM-Bezug gehabt hätte. Also Zapp hätte den Bericht trotzdem gemacht, da ging es ja gar nicht um die WM. Aber in anderen Medien habe ich viel mehr über Versilov gelesen als eben über diesen anderen Fall. Das fand ich interessant, weil es ja auch einiges aussagt.
Also WM ist ein konkretes Thema, wo sie Leute was darunter vorstellen können. Und Pussy Riot ist natürlich in Deutschland auch immer ein Aufhänger, wo jeder sofort glaubt, zu wissen, was das ist. Auch wenn viele Leute hier immer noch denken, Pussy Riot ist eine Band, wegen der Berichterstattung damals. Weil eben das ist das, womit viele in Deutschland zum ersten Mal von ihnen erfahren haben, war dieses Punkrock-Prayer oder so ähnlich. Auch wenn es ein Protest-Kollektiv ist, das sich auf unterschiedliche Arten ausdrückt, dass es nicht eine Band ist, die gerade an ihrem nächsten Album sitzt. Aber das verstehe ich. Die Geschichte mit den getöteten Journalisten in russischen Medien, auch in englischsprachigen. Ich habe da einiges von mitgekriegt. Aber ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass du nicht der Einzige warst, der über diese Tangente davon erfahren hat.
Also interessant, dass dieses Thema noch offen ist. Ich glaube, seitdem haben wir gar nicht mehr miteinander gesprochen, wie dann aufgedeckt wurde der Giftanschlag in England. Jetzt habe ich gerade den Namen vergessen. Gripal. Aber damals hatte man noch nicht die ganzen Überwachungsvideos von den beiden Russen und noch nicht das etwas... Also das war fast schon tragikomisch, dieses Interview, was sie dann dem Staatsfernsehen gegeben haben, in dem sie gesagt haben, wir wollten uns da diese eine Kathedrale angucken, und beim ersten Besuch war es aber zu verschneit, deswegen sind wir nochmal gekommen. War so skurril und das ändert ja auch was mit der Bewertung von allen Dingen, die man dann über ein Land liest. Das ist ja so, wie wir jetzt über Saudi-Arabien ganz anders sprechen, als viele noch vor wenigen Wochen über Saudi-Arabien gesprochen hätten. Natürlich nicht alle. So ein bisschen ging es mir auch bei dieser Geschichte so, dass ich den Eindruck hatte, da hat sich jetzt auch wieder in der Berichterstattung rund um Russland wirklich etwas nochmal gedreht. Es ist nochmal zwei Schritte weitergegangen in Deutschland.
Das gibt es hier bei den englisch sprachenden Kollegen. Ich glaube, das ist auch eine Kollegin von Associated Press, die hier in Russland arbeitet, die aber lustigerweise aus Salisbury ist. Die halt also sofort an diesem Interview sagen konnte, das ist totaler Quatsch. Wenn die von A nach B wollten, dann müssen wir nicht durch die Straße, müssen wir durch die Straße und so weiter. Und die dann so ein Stück darüber geschrieben hat, wie halt ihr ansonsten ja wirklich sehr hübscher kleiner Heimatort plötzlich halt Schauplatz für sowas ist. Das ist ein schönes Stück. Ich reichte dir den Link nachher mal an.
Ja, sehr, sehr gerne. Den packen wir dann auch nicht, Sean Nords. Aber ich finde, Katrin, es waren so schöne Folgen mit dir, dass wir jetzt auch auf einer leichteren Note enden müssen. Ich weiß, jetzt habe ich gerade... Ein ganz fiesen Anglizismus habe ich jetzt hier gerade ins Deutsche übersetzt. Aber du hast mir noch gesagt, wir müssen über einen Kalender sprechen. Ich weiß nicht, was für ein Kalender und worum es geht. Bitte sag mir, dass es nur Nacktfotos von Wladimir Putin sind, oder ist er, oder um was geht es?
Ich habe das Gefühl gerade, du willst dich für deinen nächsten Preis, den du gewinnen willst, ein bisschen anders positionieren.
Ja, bei der Venus will ich auftreten.
Genau, genau, sehr schön.
Was du alles kennst, ich weiß natürlich nicht mal, was das ist, die Venus. Jedenfalls dieser Kalender, der hier auf meinem Tisch liegt, während wir skypen, ich finde den bemerkenswert. Ich war hier im Domkinigi, das ist ein großer Blutladen, wir haben auch immer viele Kalender, habe so ein bisschen geguckt, was es gibt für 2019, und es gibt für 2019 einen Kalender, er ist quadratisch, er hat dieses WM Corporate Design, dieses Dunkelrot und Dunkelblau, es ist genau die WM Schrifttype und so. Und innen drin sind für jeden Monat von einem Austragungsort die quasi Stadtposter. Und das ist die Stelle, wo du jetzt sagen musst, aha, Stadtposter, was für Stadtposter.
Aha, Stadtposter, was für Stadtposter.
Denn es gab zwar offiziell für jeden Austragungsort so einen Stadtposter, aber ähnlich wie dieses Lev Yashin-Poster sind die hier dir de facto nicht begegnet. Ich fand einige von denen richtig, richtig toll. Das von Karl Liningrad ist geil, weil Karl Liningrad liegt am Wasser. Und da ist so ein Fußballspieler, der ist aus Wasser. Und der nimmt gerade mit der Brust einen Ball an. Oder, warte, wenn ich uns noch schön, ich blätter mal ein bisschen.
Ich dachte mir schon, wie sie es geschafft haben, 2019 noch einen WM-Bezug herzustellen, aber das ist natürlich nett.
Und das sind halt alles richtig, also nicht alle super genug, aber viele schöne, auch unterschiedliche grafische Motive. Sochi mit so einer Berglandschaft, ganz stilisiert, viel Schnee, aber irgendwie trotzdem ganz bunt. Das aus Samara ist irgendwie, das sieht ein bisschen nach Kunstleistungskurs aus, aber es sind viele geile bei. Und die hast du während der ganzen WM nicht gesehen. Nirgends. Ich war einmal im, also ich war öfter im IBC, in einem International Broadcasting Center, wo dann viele übertragen haben, und bei Kollegen von einer Redaktion zu Gast, und die hatten die alle da hängen. Ich hab gesagt, ihr müsst mir sofort sagen, wo ihr die her habt. Ich will die nämlich als Poster haben, da sind mehrere geile dabei, und die haben gesagt, ja, haben wir uns aus dem Internet gezogen, großgezogen und ausgedruckt. Okay, weil ist sie nicht gar. Wieder mal so eine total verpasste Merchandising-Chance. Und dass jetzt 2019, wo die WM sowas schon durch ist, kannst du sie nun also alle kaufen. Das ist ein richtiger offizieller Kalender. Also das ist ein offizielles Merchandising-Produkt. Da hinten drauf ist so ein FIFA-Rologramm, da ist ein Visa-Logo. Das ist so gedacht. Das ist ein echtes Produkt. Und ich fand das so interessant, weil das so ein schöner Bogen ist. Als wir die ersten Male miteinander gesprochen haben, haben wir ganz viel über Russland und Timing gesprochen. Woran arbeiten die gerade? Kriegen die ihre Stadien rechtzeitig hin? Sind alle Mannschaftsunterkünfte? Bist du ein Fertig? Oder kurz vor dem Turnierbeginn, wie wenig man im Stadtbild gesehen hat, dass hier in zwei, drei, vier Tagen WM ist, dass viel von der Deko erst in dem Straßenbild erschien, als das Turnier schon zwei Wochen lief. Und das hier ist für mich echt der Ausbund dieser Nummer. Jetzt wo sie, Entschuldigung, echt keiner mehr braucht, wo du im Stadtbild nichts mehr siehst. Jetzt, ein Jahr zu spät de facto, kriegst du diese wirklich sehr geilen Poster plötzlich als Kalender. Und da habe ich doch mal, was habe ich da investiert? Ich glaube 300 Rubel, 5 Euro. Dann habe ich mir so einen Kalender gekauft.
Das ist ja auch für ein offizielles Merchandising-FIFA-Produkt.
Oder?
Oder ein Schnäppchen, hast du einen Schnapper gemacht, Katrin?
Hätte ich mal zwei kaufen können, aber ich kann dir einen Putin-Kalender schicken, statt wessen.
Ich bestehe drauf. Dann würde ich den Ehren gehalten werden, aber mein Putin schreien. Ich habe mich in diesem Podcast in eine komische Richtung argumentiert. Ich weiß nicht, woran das liegt. Ich hoffe einfach, es versendet sich. Spätestens bei Kurzpass 200 wird sich dann niemand mehr daran erinnern, was da in der 100 passiert ist. Ich freue mich. Aber das ist echt ein schöner Runderbogen, auch mit dem Timing. Ich meine, immerhin hat das sportliche Timing ja besser gepasst. Die WM verlief ja viel, viel erfolgreicher als vorher zu glauben. Ich habe dir jetzt gar keine Fragen noch zu Berichterstattung gestellt, weil ich glaube, das haben wir das letzte Mal alles schon beantwortet. Ich glaube nicht, dass jetzt noch viel über Doping diskutiert wurde und über andere Themen. Ja, genau, das habe ich mir schon gedacht. Und das ist auch gar nicht so von oben herab gemeint. Das ist ja in deutschen Medien übrigens ganz gleich. Da werden ja auch nicht immer über die unangenehmen Themen berichtet. Außer natürlich, irgendwelche Fans haben was gemacht. Dann geht das Abendland unter. Wenn du wüsstest, was hier los ist, Katrin, ich kann dich nur warnen, nach Deutschland zu kommen. Fußballhorden, Gewalt und Totschlag. Ab jetzt braucht es Wasserwerfer an jeder Ecke. Ich will das nicht relativieren. Ach, Berlin, naja. Also ich will es auch nicht relativieren, aber dass das an der Stelle keiner auch nur mal über die Polizeitaktik diskutiert und dass vor allem immer die gleichen Leute dann bei solchen Punkten aus der Ecke kommen und auch in etablierten Medien, von denen ich viel gehalten habe, dann ihre Plattform bekommen, ohne dass da auch noch, wie gesagt, soll nicht relativiert werden, dass da ganz viel auch auf Seiten der Fans schiefgelaufen ist. Aber es ist unglaublich, wie einseitig die Berichterstattung ist. Und an solche Fälle muss ich immer denken, wenn gerne auch Deutsche etwas überheblich über Pressefreiheit und Meinungsbildung in anderen Ländern reden, denke ich mir, na ja, da kann man sich auch manchmal an der eigenen Nase fassen, auch wenn das andere Themen sind. Na ja, Katrin, was wird dir von der WM in Erinnerung bleiben? Jetzt ist sie dann offiziell vorbei. Also außer wir reden vielleicht noch mal nächsten Sommer und du sagst mir, wie dann die russische Liga so ist. Aber da du ja wieder zurückkommst nach Deutschland, wird es ja dann auch für dich schwieriger, da am Ball zu bleiben. Jetzt ist es wirklich vorbei. Meinst du, es wird so eine Erinnerung geben von der WM, die dich begleiten wird?
Also schön. Also wenn du mich eindringlich fragst, war es natürlich ziemlich furchtbar, in Kasan zu sitzen und zu hoffen, dass vielleicht mal irgendjemand dieses Tor trifft gegen Südkorea. Aber genauso halt so viele Erlebnisse, wo ich in Moskau in meiner Stadt unterwegs war und es plötzlich ganz anders angefühlt hat. Oder oben in der Fanzone vor der Uni zu gucken. Das Toni Großtor, das war schon ziemlich weit vorne.
Das glaube ich, das glaube ich. Wie lange wirst du denn noch dein Newsletter machen? Den Russball?
Das muss ich mal entscheiden. Ich bin mir da noch so ein bisschen unschlüssig. Also auf jeden Fall mache ich noch eine, also ich habe jetzt gerade die Oktober-Folge gemacht.
Also ich würde mich freuen, weil für mich ist es der einzige Blick in den russischen Fußball, den ich bekomme. Ich habe mich auch schon bei dem Gedanken ertappt, dass ich das gerne für viele andere Länder hätte. Also ich habe so Informations-Enklaven. Es gibt zum Beispiel im Forum bei uns ein Thread zum HSV in der zweiten Liga. Da beziehe ich alle meine Informationen her und fühle mich hervorragend informiert. Dann habe ich den russischen Fußball mit dir abgedeckt. Jetzt brauche ich noch ganz dringend jemanden, der... Ja, also der Aufruf geht auch gerne raus. Noch mal an alle Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ein paar Vorschläge habe ich schon bekommen. Wenn ihr jemanden kennt, der im Idealfall auch des Deutschen mächtig ist, auf Englisch ging es zur Not, aber auch, dann müsst ihr halt durch, dass ich dann Englisch spreche, der in Katar oder dort in der Region lebt und vor allem des Arabischen mächtig ist und mir sagen könnte, was passiert denn da, wäre ich sehr interessiert dran. Das würde ich wahrscheinlich sogar jetzt auch schon in den nächsten Monaten starten, weil wegen mir kann man ja jetzt schon alles halbe Jahr darüber sprechen. Und nicht erst, wenn alle anderen Medien dann ums Eck kommen.
Nein, das ist total ernst gemeintes Kompliment. Du musst nicht lachen. Dass du eben nicht nur in den vier Wochen dich für ein Land interessierst, wo da ein Turnier ist.
Nee, das finde ich eigentlich genau am langweiligsten, weil da machen es ja alle. Nee, ich bin für was Langfristiges. Ich werde sofort mein Tinder-Profil updaten. Und deswegen muss ich jetzt auch diese Folge hier beenden. Katrin, es war wie immer eine sehr, sehr große Freude, dass du mit dabei warst. At karscheib auf Twitter. Und auf karscheib.de findet ihr auch den Newsletter. Und damit auch danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörern, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Ich glaube, um das WM-2018-Thema können wir jetzt ein Schleifchen machen. Mit einem leichten, tränenen Auge. Irgendwie hat das sehr, sehr viel Spaß gemacht, trotz FIFA und dem ganzen anderen Kram. Danke euch für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war der 100. Kurzpass. Auch eigentlich kaum zu glauben. Und dann hören wir uns wieder in irgendeiner der nächsten Rasenfunk-Folgen. Bis dahin, macht es gut, habt eine gute Zeit. Und ciao.